you had a rich and spicy vegetable soup
and you're wondering if the audio is
spicy do I sound spicy you sound rich
and wholesome like I'm not sure that's a
compliment but nevertheless at this
altitude I can run my hands shake this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
longtime listeners of this podcast know
that I've been talking about fresh books
for years it's the all-in-one invoicing
payments and accounting solution it came
about because I was doing a revision of
the 4-hour workweek for 2009 looking at
new software solutions that could help
people help my readers and first books
came up over and over and over again
many entrepreneurs as well as
contractors and freelancers I work with
all the time use fresh books more and
more every day why is that well most
people especially entrepreneurs business
builders hate wasting time doing things
in efficiently painful invoicing with
different cobble together solutions
including Word or Excel can fall into
that category if you want to avoid that
pain what can you do give fresh books a
try fresh books is accounting software
that makes invoicing and other
bookkeeping tasks so easy you can save
up to 200 hours per year that's a lot of
hours here's how it makes running your
business easier you can automate bank
reconciliation in just a few clicks
you can give your accountant access to
the information they need to do your
taxes this is a huge one I've realized
how important this is and how much it
makes life easier when you get this done
with many things you can't accept credit
card and ACH payments right on invoices
to get paid two times faster and of
course you can create customized and
send branded and professional-looking
invoices in about 30 seconds with plans
starting at just 15 dollars per month
fresh books is designed to grow with
your business and right now first books
is offering my listeners that's you guys
a free 30-day trial with no credit card
required simply go to fresh books
/ Tim and enter Tim Farriss in the how
did you hear about us section that's
Ferris with two hours into us is of
course check it out go to FreshBooks
comm / Tim and start your free 30-day
trial today first books calm / Tim this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for you to find and work with
amazing graphic designers online
longtime listeners of this podcast know
how much attention I paid to detail how
obsessively I approach nearly all
elements of my work because the small
things often end up being the big thing
so whether it's your logo your business
cards website design even your email
templates all of these visual elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about so I think
it's worth sweating the details I've
been using 99designs for years now to
ensure that many of my creative projects
whether big or small are as cohesive
professional and beautiful as possible
I've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers I've worked on all sorts of
things most recently I've been working
with a designer at 99 designs to update
the illustrations and layouts for all of
my downloadable ebooks I've developed a
really great working relationship with
the designer who goes by the username
spoon Lancer and I intend to continue
working with him to bring ideas to life
one project at a time I've also used 99
designs for all sorts of high-end
illustration for different books like
the Tao Seneca you can see a bunch of
examples on my Instagram that I've put
up and they've turned out better than I
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books 99 designs is the go to
creative resource to build your brand on
any budget so check them out right now
my listeners that's you guys can get $20
off plus a free $99 upgrade on their
first design contest a contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer for long-term work you
can also book a free design consultation
with a brand expert at 99 designs to
receive personalized branding advice
over the phone they're hands-on team has
helped thousands of business owners at
this point it's a great way to get the
most out of your experience with 99
designs so take a look head - 99 designs
dot-com / Tim for your discount and to
sign up
for design consultation today that's
99designs dot-com / tim hello boys and
girls ladies and germs but who wants to
think about germs these days this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to interview and deconstruct world
class performers of different types to
tease out the habits routines frameworks
practices etc that you can apply in your
own life this episode is more of a
personal therapy session for yours truly
in some respects and features jack
Kornfield and i want to say a few things
before we jump into his bio the first is
that my hope is that you will listen to
portions of this conversation multiple
times there are a number of exercises
that Jack shares that I will be
certainly listening to in the upcoming
weeks multiple times and I suggest you
think of this as a menu from which you
can choose different things you can use
repeatedly that's number one number two
you will notice that I sound anxious I
sound unsure in this interview and that
is very much by design in other words
I'm not trying to hide the fact that I
also struggle I think it is unhelpful
when people in the public eye do that
and it puts them on this illusory
pedestal that is I think ultimately
self-defeating
and instead I want to share with you
that no matter how much stoic philosophy
I read no matter how often I meditate
there are times when I struggle and this
week is one of them so with all that
said who is jack Kornfield
jack Kornfield you can find him on
twitter at jack Kornfield kor & fi eld
at jack Kornfield comm jack trained is a
buddhist monk in the monasteries of
thailand india and burma shortly
thereafter becoming one of the key
teachers to introduce Buddhist
mindfulness practice to the West he is
taught meditation internationally since
1974 Jack has also had a profound and
direct impact on my life and I'm
thrilled to have him on the podcast
once again Jack co-founded
Insight Meditation Society in Barre
Massachusetts with fellow meditation
teachers Sharon Salzberg and Joseph
Goldstein and the spirit Rock Center in
wood acre California he holds a PhD in
clinical psychology and is a father
husband and activist he has a very
expanded broad spectrum toolkit and has
worked with veterans has worked with
adolescents who self-harm cutters etc he
has a wealth of experience as a
clinician so he is not limited to
meditation practices I feel that's
important to underscore Jack's books
have been translated into 22 languages
and sold more than one-and-a-half
million copies including the Y's heart a
lamp in the darkness a path with heart
after the ecstasy the laundry one of my
favorite book titles of all time and his
most recent no time like the present
subtitle finding freedom love and joy
right where you are he offers a
brilliant online training program and I
don't use that adjective lightly for
those who want to learn to teach
meditation at jack Kornfield comm and he
is co-leading that with Tara brach who I
also have a very high opinion of and who
has been on this podcast so definitely
check out his course at jack Kornfield
comm and without further ado please
enjoy this what was for me a very
valuable conversation with jack
Kornfield
Jack welcome to the show oh thank you
Tim I'm happy to be back I am thrilled
to have you back and for purposes of
context for people listening and
recording this Monday March 9th 2020 and
things are very exciting in quotation
marks at the moment and I am perhaps not
so secretly going to use this
conversation which is intended to be
listened to by my audience as a therapy
session for myself I will confess Jack
that only very recently in the last even
few days have I ever in my life taken
prescription medication for sleeping and
I know that I'm not alone and perhaps
struggling to not necessarily make sense
of but contend with a lot of what is
happening currently with the novel
coronavirus Cove at 19 etcetera and I
thought we would start with the with the
the topic that I had written down here
at the very top and that is talking
about a large virtual class you taught
recently in China could you speak to
what that was and what the experience
was like I taught a class in China of
people who'd been involved in meditation
so it was through a community of people
I know there are many folks who are
already under quarantine at home and
dealing with the collective anxiety and
fears that are happening the incredible
disruption that's happened in in China
which may well be happening here it
looks like it's actually coming to us in
a very rapid fashion so we talked about
how to hold it all and you know to get
them to laugh a little bit I said you
know we have at our Center in California
and Spirit Rock we have a whole group of
people who are on our winter spring
two-month retreat 100 plus folks
who are mostly in their own little rooms
they met it taped quietly together they
can't go out they can't talk to anyone
and they paid lots of money to do it I
said and you get this for free what what
will it mean take your circumstance and
even though there is anxiety or fear or
you know again not able to sleep all the
kind of disruptions what if you were to
turn it around and say the universe has
provided you with a retreat that you
might not have had any opportunity to do
in your life in this way and to use it
somehow to deepen your compassion your
self-care the wisdom you have and I said
because I used the image that is so
powerful from the Vietnamese Zen master
take not Hanh he said when the crowded
Vietnamese refugee boats met with storms
or pirates if everyone panicked all
would be lost but if even one person on
the boat remain calm and centered it was
enough it showed the way for everyone to
survive and I said so these are tough
times and it's quite obvious you know
that we're in this complex of cultural
anxiety and the spread of the virus and
so forth you can either give in to or
get lost in your fear and anxiety or you
can take this as a time to begin to
train yourself in steadiness and trust
in the ability to have a vaster and
broader perspective and perhaps more
than anything with a kind of common
humanity to develop your sense of care
and connection more deeply for everyone
else this is the time that the
Bodhisattva which is a Buddhist term for
a being who commits to compassion turns
toward the difficult circumstances
and makes their own heart zone of peace
and compassion and says we know how to
hold this we've been training our whole
lives for this difficulty and now let us
see if we can use this so it's not
happening to us but it's happening for
us and that reverses the frame of it now
I don't mean this is easy but it is
actually true circumstances can change
it said like the swish of a horse's tail
from something benevolent to something
difficult and when you enter a retreat
especially a long retreat as I did in my
own training and Buddhist monasteries
they will often say during this retreat
many people will be born many people
will die and your task is to come to
that great inner freedom that can hold
birth and death and joy and sorrow and
be a benevolent and liberated spirit or
liberated force in the midst of it all
so we had this kind of conversation and
people talked about their concerns with
their family and obviously their
economic fears which I worry about more
broadly here in the US how many small
businesses will be affected and how many
people who live from one paycheck to the
next and that just touches my heart even
to say it and at the same time maybe
this wake up also is a call for us here
to have universal health care because in
fact you know it doesn't matter how rich
you are when you go out in your car you
go out to the market you're surrounded
by all these other people and if
everybody around you doesn't have the
necessary care then it will inevitably
affect you because more and more we can
feel how we are tied together so what do
we do with this I ask them we can either
get lost in our fearful fantasies or we
can let them go or give the
a safe place the way to work with
anxiety to begin with is to acknowledge
it anxiety and fear and say thank you
thank you for trying to protect me I'm
okay for now and put them aside
you can even visualize putting them
aside you can take your fears and
anxieties as thoughts or images and put
them into a bowl or put them into a
sword and place them on an altar in your
mind and say all right may the Wise Ones
if the past may the Buddha's in the
whoever it is that you admire you hold
this for a while it's not my job to hold
this and let me be the the person who
lives in the reality of the present with
a with a centered spirit and a
compassionate heart and that kind of
conversation got a lot of response as a
reminder really of what we know and for
people who want to explore the exercise
you just described I'd actually highly
suggest our first conversation because
you may or may not recall but we spoke
about anger specifically my anger or
anger response to certain circumstances
which included a discussion of
contractor ease as you put it well yeah
I don't have to get into you but people
can explore that in the first
conversation we had I would like to
follow up with a question about the
distinction and the labels I'm going to
use or somewhat clumsy but the how to
combine what Bruce Tift I believe his
name as you wrote a book called already
free calls the developmental view and
the fruitional view or the developmental
framework and for tional framework
meaning that you have a developmental
framework that one could associate with
Western psychotherapy where you identify
problems you work through your problems
you improve your circumstances maybe you
ask for that raise quit that job have
the difficult discussion with your
spouse whatever it might be so it's a
personal development
/ improvement path and some
respect problem-solving path then the
fruitional view which at least as he
would put it is improving your ability
or changing your lens through which you
relate to your circumstances
so for yourself how old are you now jack
if you don't let me asking about to turn
seventy five seventy five so while it's
a wild number because inside of course I
don't and very often we don't feel
anywhere near as old as those numbers
that you know roll by and inside I don't
know how what age I feel fifty thirty
because it's all just a concept right so
how do you in let's just say the current
circumstances think about how much of
your mind space or energy to dedicate to
relating to the anxiety and fear and so
on differently or with an accepting
heart and so you don't become lost as
you put it in these overblown fantasies
in some cases versus the kind of brass
tacks of problem solving where you're
taking steps to disinfect packages
you're taking steps to socially distance
etc etc etc thinking about medications
you might need for the next two to three
months if there are shortages how do you
how do you think about or suggest if you
blend those two because I do see people
who fall in a binary way a hundred
percent on one side or the other and
that doesn't strike me as ideal yeah one
side would be almost a kind of denial
and just carrying on or saying well you
know the outer doesn't matter and the
other is to get lost in the future right
you're fearful fearful fantasies when
when the future is still really unknown
for us part of what happens for me and I
think as we mature become wiser is that
we become comfortable with paradox
the way to put it most simply as you
need to remember your Buddha nature and
your social security number right there
there are there different dimensions to
our our being just as light can be
measured as a particle or a wave
depending how you examine it and it's
there it is in its particle form and you
can see it or there it is as a as a wave
function in the same way consciousness
itself can be experienced differently it
can be experienced as a field of the
vast timeless awareness it can also be
experienced in each moment as the
consciousness of what's here almost as
if it's a particle and we we human
beings have this miraculous capacity to
hold these multiple dimensions in a wise
and open heart
so I recommend to people of course be
sensible any you know any good spiritual
teacher says what they want from
students is you know a student who's
dedicated yes and also who has some
common sense and not just lost in
illusion so be practical and in your
community be careful because this virus
is spreading and it will spread further
there's not a question of it and the
question war is there's a collective and
an individual one for us as individuals
how can we go through this and tend
ourselves and others with care and not
spiral down inwardly into a place of
fear or despair right and this is
possible we've done this as human beings
we're survivors and we have generations
have ancestors behind you that are
cheering you on and saying yeah we live
through some stuff tough stuff too and I
remember being in the in the forest
monastery and I got very sick at
different times as a monk were in in
that period of my life training can you
just for people who don't have contacts
explain the
force monastery what you sure when when
when I became interested in Buddhism I
went in the 1960s to Thailand where I
worked for some time in the Peace Corps
on tropical medicine teams in various
remote villages and then I became a
Buddhist monk in monasteries of the
forests of the area of Thailand and Laos
that were still huge vast for us and in
that in those monasteries we lived very
very simply you know took our almsbowl
out to the nearby village to walk and
get whatever food we could and you know
sewed and made our own robes and it was
a marvelous way of life and one that was
ancient and much of it was really the
training we did a lot of meditation we
also did various kinds of communal
practices and service and things like
that was learning how to be steady and
balanced and compassionate to ourself
and others through all the ups and downs
so I remember when I was sick with
malaria
I had typhoid to there various things I
went through and I was lying on the kind
of wooden floor of my little hut in the
forest and didn't go to the daily
chanting or whatever so the teacher came
to see me and he said how are you I said
I've got a I'm really sick he felt me I
said you have a high fever I said yeah
he looked at me quite knowingly he said
it's probably malaria I said it probably
is he said makes you feel bad doesn't it
that's it yeah really suffering he
looked at me I said yes really suffering
he says makes you think about going home
to your mother doesn't it and I smiled
because he was a very funny guy I said
absolutely he said this is malaria all
of us who lived in the jungle have had
it now there's good medicines and I'll
send the medicine monk to help you later
but remember no matter how hard it is
you know how to practice with this we've
all done
and he smiled he looked at me says you
can do this and and he actually urged me
to sit up in the middle of it there I
was sweating and chills he said sit with
it meditate with it and you'll find your
Center in the midst of it all so that
was the kind of training and in some way
we all have that training in our lives
we know their choices where we go down
the rabbit hole of our fears and get
lost and contracted and that's fine you
can say thank you thank you for trying
to take care of me as you you know as
you might to your fears but then you
remember that who you are is not limited
to that and this is the shift of
identity that who you are is bigger than
the thoughts and the fears or worries
and when you remember who you really are
with which is awareness itself a vast
loving awareness then you can look at
the circumstances hold them with great
compassion and say well how do I want to
live now how do I want to follow this
and the beautiful thing is that you
learned that you don't have to pick up
all those difficult thoughts and carried
them around
we were out wandering in the rice
paddies on the way to a village to
collect alms food one day with my
teacher ajahn Chah and some monks and
out across the rice paddies was this
great big rock a boulder and ajahn Chah
said is that boulder heavy to us he
asked the question kind of the way is in
master wood and being intelligent young
monks we said yes it is master and he
smiled and he said not if you don't pick
it up there had to be a trick coming I
knew there's something coming and it was
and it was it was something that we
learned inside of how how to witness
what's present without being lost in it
and so let's my or let's stay with the
question of the spread of this virus
because our our society isn't very well
prepared but we can prepare ourselves we
can prepare our hearts so that we're
that one on the boat whether we stay in
our homes at times that we need to and
take it as a time of deepening our our
sense of presence and care for others it
also means that we can become altruistic
it can bring out the best in us and let
me tell you a story this was on BBC some
not so many years ago they did a special
on the 60th anniversary of the siege of
leningrad in world war ii and leningrad
was besieged by the german army for
almost three years through three long
winters and there were hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people inside
many who were close to starving and one
older woman who had been there as a
child was describing the experience and
she said we would go out once a week she
said in in the winter I went out to pick
up bread for my mother and myself and
the streets were icy and slippery and I
stood in the bread line and when and got
my piece of bread and as I came out I
fell on the ice and the bread fell into
the mud puddle and I sat there and I
wept I was a young girl and another
woman walked out behind me who had
received her bread and she picked help
picked me up and she tore her piece of
bread in half and wrapped it in a cloth
and handed it to me and then this old
woman led the camera down the hallway of
her railroad type apartment into the
kitchen and opened a cabinet there was a
a ceramic which she pulled open and
pulled out a blue kerchief and untied it
and inside was
part of that piece of bread and she said
what that woman did for me is she gave
me the spirit to live through the next
year and a half of the be of the siege
and I'll never forget it
well so we have the opportunity even in
difficult times to let our spirit shine
hmm maybe maybe especially in difficult
times and and it I've been thinking a
lot of an expression recently and how it
might apply to me and how I'm responding
to current life events and world events
for that matter and I don't know the
attribution so I apologized whoever
actually said or wrote this but that
adversity does not build character it
reveals character have you seen any and
let's just take for the time being that
to be true whether it is or it isn't but
let's just let's assume that to be true
have you seen any patterns and the
people who are having the greatest
difficulty emotionally psychologically
with the spread of this novel
coronavirus are and is there anything to
be learned from that that can help
people well the first thing to say is
that I've seen people I have a friend
who's a doctor who's going around and
visiting anybody who is God symptoms and
she's you know from from the outside you
might call it heroic in some way but she
said but this is what I trained for this
is the oath that we take as physicians
then we'll actually be there and so it
dreams out what's beautiful in lots of
people however as you say if we have a
tendency to worry which many people do
or if we have a tendency to feel
ourselves to be small if our identity is
built somehow or around the sense of
separateness then this connect
exacerbated what's helpful is to have a
bigger perspective the Ojibwa
Indian Native Americans have this
amazing
I find poetic way of putting it they say
sometimes I go about pitying myself when
all the while I'm being carried by great
winds across the sky and and we're in
this human incarnation for a certain
measure of time no one knows how long
they have a beautiful and difficult and
remarkable dance in this life and how we
do it we're being carried by vastness
and we're not just this personality or
our history or the small sense of self
your spirit that was born into your body
they were lure the loving awareness that
was born into this incarnation and you
get to remember who you are as you start
to awaken and it gives you a tremendous
kind of freedom so my hope is that
people will see their habits and also
remember that who they are the Buddhist
texts begin with the words Oh nobly born
or you who are the sons and daughters of
the lineages of the awakened ones
remember who you really are that it will
actually bring out what's beautiful in
people hmm you know I asked I think this
is this is relevant to a question I
asked earlier in so much as you strike
me as someone who relates to life and
death and mortality perhaps differently
than many folks including many people
have had on this podcast and you
mentioned that you're about to turn 75 I
think you've got lots of mileage left
and I also know that older segments of
the population as it relates to kovat 19
at least appear to be more susceptible
yes to severe illness and and death and
many people including myself are worried
about their parents
and are not perhaps in some cases for
the first time but certainly right now a
lot of people are looking at mortality
or feeling the sort of imminent looming
specter of death in some capacity or the
the potential of death and struggling
with that how do you relate to death and
mortality so I want to tell a little
story of relation to my twin brother
when he died and I don't remember so
well we did in the last podcast so if I
represent okay
no problem I think it may be relevant
and then from it maybe we can talk about
how one learns to face death in a
different way so these years a few years
ago my twin brother who was a
accomplished and acclaimed scientist and
a geneticist Senna and a world Explorer
he was a population biologist more than
anything else so he explored the
underwater genomes of the great lakes of
the world and lake malawi in africa and
lake baikal and Siberian Lake Titicaca
and the Andes and so forth and genetic
diversity and all those sort of things
he did lots else he was an acclaimed
professor but he got blood cancer and
after time it morphed into a leukemia
that they were not able in the end he
had a in a stem cell transplant and all
kinds of good treatment but they were
not able to stop so I was with him in
the weeks before he died and I loved him
a lot he was a you know as a twin and a
a funny you know high-spirited
interesting playful human being but
there he was lying and knowing that he
was going to die soon
and I thought well maybe I'll teach you
meditation I said to him but he'd been
in some pain and you know in all kinds
of states and I realized pretty quickly
that it was a little late for that I
mean yes I could do a couple guided
meditations but mostly it was beyond his
doing some inner training so I said how
about instead if I meditate with you and
I'll meditate out loud and so you get a
sense of how I do this and he was a
member of the Explorers Club in you know
which has the people who first climbed
Everest or went to the north pole or the
South Pole or went amoun all these great
explorers I said will they take in her
explorers she said no no we only do the
others okay I said well so I closed my
eyes I was sitting next to his bed and I
began to meditate and I said I'm simply
paying attention with a loving awareness
to what's here in body heart and mind my
my main practice is that of opening to
what so and learning from it and there
are different channels or perspectives
that open up so I said I'm tuning in
right here and it closed my eyes and
after a minute or so I said my body is
feeling cold and the cold is centered in
my testicles and in my in my penis and
you know right in my groin and it's
getting colder it's like ice and I'm
paying as I continue to pay attention
and I said and this is death I feel it
because our our minds and bodies as
twins were really linked I feel death
growing in my body and he said so what
do you do and I said you pay attention
to it and so I sat with that for a
little bit and I said now I feel my
attention moving from the ice in my
genitals up to my heart and all of a
sudden the temperature changes and I
feel my heart
like an oven and a color kind of red
becomes and I feel a love that I've had
for you since we were in the womb or
maybe lifetimes past who knows but this
love I feel is outside of time that
whether I'm with you in your body or not
we love each other and I feel a rest a
connection in this love that's huge and
warm and keeps us connected forever and
I stayed with that for time and I said
now my attention is moving spontaneously
up to my head and my head's dissolved
and now I feel myself to be vast space
and awareness itself which is how I
practice often in meditation and I said
in this place I can sense that there's a
body here or some sensations of mine and
a sense of a body over there because I
can see and hear and feel yours
they're just appearances on the screen
of timeless awareness coming and going
and who we are is so much bigger than
this
we are the field of consciousness itself
that manifests in these incarnations and
in this I feel absolutely at peace and
open and spacious and when I opened my
eyes and looked at him he had become
much more peaceful it's as if he had
taken in these dimensions and it had
reminded him of something that he knew
deep in himself because these are the
different dimensions of freedom that
come as one trains in meditation and so
let me talk about that a tiny bit and
then I'll get back to your question
about death because there is no no were
there that's why we're interesting as
well there are four dimensions of
freedom that you learn as you train in
we'll call it meditation or in the inner
capacities of presence
and each of them involve a shift of
identity the first is that you become
more and more able to be present with
the content of your experience with what
is called the ten thousand joys and the
ten thousand sorrows so as you all are
use saving as the example as you sit and
meditate you'll have your longing and
your love and your itches and your
worries and your anger and your joy and
your creativity and your imagination and
your pain and the knee you know and your
resentments and you have all of those
things come and the first thing the
first dimension of freedom that grows
for you is what the neuroscientists call
expanding the window of tolerance they
are able to tolerate your humanity with
its broken heart and it's incredible
love you know with the unbearable beauty
of the world you live in and the ocean
of Tears and the poet I believe it's a
fascist don't surrender your loneliness
so quickly let it cut more deeply let it
season you as few ingredients can and so
you sit with your loneliness and you
learn to say AHA this is loneliness and
give about to it and say yes thank you
for your song and you sit with your love
and you acknowledge that you sit with
the difficulty or shame that many people
carry I remember working with this man
who'd been an orphan and he felt like
there was something wrong with him
because he was put into an orphanage
even though it was nothing that that he
as a child had done and you learn to
tolerate your humanity and that already
brings a tremendous kind of freedom and
then the next dimension of freedom and
they're they're not in order they're
different dimensions of because we are
we are able to hold we're beings of
multi-level or parrot
is not just the content but the process
or the common humanity of experience and
you start to realize that what you take
so personally is just what life is
Zorba the Greek says trouble life is
trouble only death is nice he goes on
and you start to see you know that there
are different kinds of tears there the
tears from your own trauma and being you
know hurt or wounded or abandoned or
abused that need to be honored and we
might talk about trauma more later but
there's another kind of tears that are
called the tears of the way and those
are the tears of the Dharma where you
realize when you face your own
loneliness or longing or the way that
you've been mistreated all of a sudden
you realize oh loneliness and longing
comes with being human praise and blame
come with being human joy and sorrow
come with being human I think last time
I told you this story of being with Pema
Chodron with this person this woman
whose partner had committed suicide and
how terrible that was for her impairment
telling her to hold it all with
compassion and then I asked in this room
of two or three thousand people for
people to raise their hands or stand up
if someone in their family had committed
suicide or someone close to them you
know in two or three hundred people
stood up and all of a sudden that woman
gazed back at them I asked her to look
and they at her and the room became a
holy place because there was so much
common humanity of that which the heart
has to bear and yet we know we can bear
when we are connected with others and so
the second dimension or aspect of
freedom
is our common humanity that it's not
personal that you have suffering or that
people get sick or that you have
triumphs and successes and you you know
make a name for yourself or or build
something beautiful these are part of
what human incarnation does and you
begin to hold it all not as me and mine
but as part of this great dance and it's
all both impermanent and not so personal
it has both its you know joys and its
suffering and the heart grows wider to
hold this and and then the next
dimension which opens up further and and
kind of talks to that question you
talked about developmental versus
fruition practice and I'll get back to
it is the dimension of awareness itself
my teacher ajahn Chah this great
meditation master in the forests of
Thailand and Laos had lived in caves and
done austere practices and long days and
months of meditation and out in the
jungles where there still were Tigers
and all those things and he had deep
insights and visions and you know lots
of suffering but also tremendous
insights and beautiful states of Samadhi
and Awakening and he went to see the
greatest master of his time another a
john or teacher named Rajan Mun and told
him about all the things that had
happened in his meditation and insights
and understandings in beautiful states
that had come of dissolving his body
into light and so forth and a
gentleman's response was cha dude you've
missed the point he said those are just
experiences they're like movies on a
screen you sit and you have the war
movie and you have the movie of conflict
at work and you sit and you have the
romantic comedy and you have the
documentary
he said they're all happening they arise
in past those are not the point
the point he says it's because none of
those can be held on to they all come
and go the question is to whom do they
happen turn your attention back to the
one who knows to the knowing there was a
phrase he used it's Sikhi Bhutto to the
one who knows and become the witnessing
of all of this because who you really
are is consciousness itself manifesting
in the different forms that are
experienced but consciousness itself is
timeless and pure and open vast like the
sky containing all things but not
limited by them and when you become the
loving awareness itself then this is the
gateway to an even greater dimension of
freedom and then since I'm going on and
on here I'll add the fourth dimension of
freedom which is that as you become
familiar with and remember and remind
yourself and discover that you can be a
loving awareness that you are the
witness to things all these things
change but even now as you listen to him
and those people are listening to this
podcast and you feel your body seated
there in a chair or you're in your car
or wherever you are listening and you
hear the sounds and the other sounds
around you you know in the sights there
is a consciousness that knows these turn
your attention from the experience to
the mystery of consciousness that is
ever-present this is the one who knows
the knowing rest in it it is your true
home and from this place then there
opens one more dimension of freedom as
my teacher in India
Rena's Argonaut said wisdom tells me I
am nothing
love tells me I am everything between
these two my life flows and as you
become the witness of these words of
your body of experience of life it's not
that you remove yourself from life but
you actually become more intimate with
it you become able to hold it in this
great heart mind that word in Sanskrit
is chitta which means both heart and
mind that is loving awareness and with
loving awareness not only is there
spaciousness but there's also intimate
connection and so your love grows for
this mystery of life even as your
freedom grows and so these are the
different dimensions of they're part of
the training that we do when we train
teachers in meditation but these are the
different dimensions of freedom that are
possible for us and as you learn these
they allow you to enter the terrain of
birth and death with a wise and spacious
heart so I'd be happy to talk more about
that but let me take a pause here
because I've been going for a while and
I wonder how this sounds to you
I enjoy this type of discussion so it
makes sense to me conceptually
experientially and perhaps we'll get to
this point or what we'll cover this
topic at some point I think particularly
with certain adjunct assistance in ego
dissolution I feel as though I've from
an experiential standpoint also perhaps
glanced on the edges of some of these
dimensions personally and I suppose as
as the shepherd of my listeners the hits
landed is both very very fascinating and
wondering how for someone who is in pain
currently thing
hanging about ruminating upon perhaps
just perseverating with the topic of
mortality and death the
uncontrollability of vastly changing
circumstances perhaps they're separated
on opposite sides of the country from
their parents or grandparents and
recognize that healthcare systems may be
overwhelmed etc etc is there is there
something that they can do just as a
triage practice they may not go through
all of these dimensions but is there
anything they can do in terms of
practice or anything you can share that
might give them some reprieve or lessen
the severity of that anxiety that's
associated with all that yes there are a
few things that they can do in it I'm
grateful for the practical dimension of
your question so first I want to answer
personally I've had a really good life
so I feel in many ways complete and so
what will happen in terms of death I
don't particularly want to die I'd like
to be there for my grandson Desmond
who's now approaching one and a half
years old I want to play you know tag
and ball watch things and you know watch
him develop and grow and all that but I
also feel at peace with myself that
being said of course people are going to
be afraid and of course they're going to
be worried for whether it's their
parents who are older or other people
they know who are vulnerable or
themselves so here are several different
things that are important the first is
to stop and just to sit down for a
little bit and maybe put your hand on
your heart every day and remind yourself
let me hold all of what I'm worried
about with a tender compassion bringing
the element of compassion because we
human beings go through difficult things
let me hold myself and my worry
and my parents or my friends who are
vulnerable
may they be safe and well you can sort
of extend your well-wishing may we hold
ourselves with tenderness and compassion
so this sort of brings that altruistic
quality and reminds us that we can hold
things with kindness not to judge
yourself even you know you think well I
shouldn't be worried so much or I should
this or I shouldn't be anxious again
just say thank you for trying to take
care of me and then the next step is to
notice I'm okay for now and this becomes
really important because your parents
are ok for now or the people you worry
about are oh ok for now it doesn't mean
they shouldn't prepare or get your masks
or sequester yourself you know or line
up the kind of care you might need or
medications but to live where you are to
come back and say I'm ok for now and
feel yourself rooted in the earth
another thing that you can do you feel
yourself connected to the earth is
literally to go outside and find a
beautiful Boulder a rock or a tree and
stand with it and feel the roots of the
tree look at it and since how it goes
into the earth and how that tree lives
through winds and storm and loses its
leaves and regains them and how life
keeps renewing itself and stand with
that tree and feel how you too can root
yourself in the earth how you can stand
in the winds of change and feel grounded
and steady and flexible and find those
qualities in yourself again you can take
your images of worry and fear thank them
for trying to protect you and visualize
placing them in a bowl or into some
other form and put them on an altar and
that altar in your mind
can be filled with the you know the
image of whoever or whatever you take to
be sacred it can be the Buddha and Quan
Yin or Jesus or mother Mary you know or
Gandhi or whoever it is or if you have
an altar at home because some people do
and they put their favorite spiritual
inspiration on it you can write your
worries on a piece of paper seal all the
energy of those fears in your body the
emotions of it the stories and then fold
the paper up and bring it to your altar
and put it in the lap of Quan Yin or in
front of mother Mary and say you hold
these now I will do what I can for my
parents I'll take care of myself and my
family and community I'll let you carry
the fears I'm gonna do it from a place
of centeredness and courage no to as you
do this that just as I talked about with
with a vastness don't be squeamish about
letting things go you can actually let
go of some thoughts and feelings it
doesn't mean they won't be there they'll
come up again but you can say you know
not now I put you on the altar I let you
go I put you back into the earth and and
instead I'm now going to shift my
consciousness to calm and spaciousness
and vastness and feel your breath
breathing in and out as it does and feel
how life has carried you and let
yourself open to a space of steadiness
and calm and maybe link your spirit with
all those others who are steady and calm
in the world right now just as you are
the thousands and thousands who found a
way to be calm and steady the physicians
and nurses you know the fathers and
mothers of children who
found their way to attend one another
with a steadiness in a calm and linked
your consciousness with them so these
are a few of many practices to suggest
and this is important to say also that
it's a not a one-time thing that's why
they're called practice and not perfect
because you do it you lose it you kind
of get lost again you can't sleep as you
said Tim or you get lost in worries and
then you can't sleeping you say all
right let me sit up and meditate and let
me meditate on vas listen let me become
the the Bodhisattva of peace and
compassion and extend my compassion to
everyone else who can't sleep tonight
and we'll meditate together and we'll
meditate on our connection and love and
little by little you'll get bored just
doing the compassion over and over and
you'll fall back asleep it strikes me
that this well a number of things strike
me first for people who have not ever
tried this the the visualization of
placing these various feelings or
concerns on an altar or with other
advice-giving sources you respect or
physically putting it on your altar is
at least has been for me surprisingly
effective and not only that but it
doesn't have to take a long time it's
it's the power of the metaphor for me at
least has been very effective and
certainly Jack you've helped me in many
other instances over the years the
linking of consciousness with others I
think is something I haven't quite paid
enough attention to and that that
strikes me also that it could be
particularly important and nourishing
when people are say social distancing or
self quarantine or otherwise isolated or
feeling physically isolated so I thought
that strikes me as as a very good
practice and I had
follow-up question which was could you
maybe expound a bit or expand a bit on
don't be squeamish about letting things
go because I think I need to hear
perhaps maybe just you repeat what you
said or elaborates a little bit well it
makes me think about Ramdas who we may
talk about as we go on as well and
that's story when he was teaching as
Baba Ram Dass and had just come back
from India with his white robes and
beads and so forth and doing
offering Hindu and Buddhist meditation
some of what we just did and some Hindu
mantras and this woman in the front row
said around us are you Jewish come on
that's what's what's with the Hindu
stuff and Ram Dass smile and he said I
am he said and I I was as he's pointed
out he said it was bar mitzvah'd as I
was and there's a lot that I love in the
Jewish spiritual tradition the Hasidic
masters are like the Zen masters you
read this stories and the Kabbalah has
all these dimensions of consciousness
and then he smiled and he said but
remember I'm only Jewish on my parents
side and it was as he was a witty
comment but also a profound one because
we can get lost in things that we're
identified with and really take them to
be ourselves but then in a moment we can
also say oh that's just common humanity
that's just and we can step back and not
take take it so personally and in this
case it's like your whole history your
parents your trauma you know your gender
or whatever all those things are given
to you in this incarnation in a certain
way but in another way who you really
are is bigger than all of that and so
then you can also spread out your
consciousness or open to that vastness
and say I'm going to connect myself with
everyone in the world who still
in calm right now we will do this
together so I don't know if that helps
but it does it does help and you also
mentioned a name that I know some
listeners will not recognize and that is
Quan Yin now speaking is someone who's
spent some time at spirit rock and
actually had some very challenging times
in my first silent meditation over an
extended period of time which you're
very gracious and generous and helping
me to get through there's a very large
wooden carving of Quan Yin at spirit
rock who is Quan Yin and what is the
significance of Quan Yin for you as a as
a symbol or an avatar or an icon so part
of what's interesting about
consciousness is that it works in the
minut particulars you know your toenails
and the the kind of breakfast you ate
this morning you know and the number of
people in your family and what kind of
carpet or would you have on the floor
that it has the specifics of life but it
also has an archetypal dimension which
is to say it has patterns the archetypes
are the patterns of life there's the
pattern of you know houses or places to
live whether they're you know huts or or
thatched or caves or wooden or concrete
or something they all fit under the
pattern or the archetype of a home and
in in the spiritual language the
archetypes of awakened consciousness
which are sometimes described as you
know great wise beings and so forth
they're many many kinds and Quan Yin is
a bodhisattva bodhisattva is a compound
word that means Bodhi is awakened and
Safa is being
who's committed to compassion and the
freedom or the awakening of all beings
and there's lots and lots of
Bodhisattvas and in fact I think there's
lots of Bodhisattvas in my neighborhood
people who treat one another beautifully
who help uplift one another who have a
free heart we know Bodhisattvas so Quan
Yin is the name for a Buddhist
archetypal Bodhisattva she is the
consciousness of universal compassion
and sometimes she's depicted with a
thousand arms and a thousand hands
enough to reach out to respond to the
needs of the whole universe so we have
these images of Quan Yin because she's a
as an archetype she's a symbol of
compassion itself and we can become that
the beautiful thing is not that there's
some you know symbol on the wall or
carved statue in whatever tradition it
is but that these are really symbols for
what lives within us and so we have we
have all these capacities and depending
which ones we take not Hanh used to talk
about it as seeds in consciousness
depending which ones we water and tend
those are what blossom if we water and
tend our anger it will grow if we water
and tend and spend time and our our
fears or you know our conflict they will
grow if we water the seeds of peace in
us they'll grow if we water the seeds of
compassion in consciousness then tend to
it it will blossom in the invitation of
these archetypes is to realize that we
have this in us it's not separate from
us and also I think there's something
else people kind of approach spiritual
life as a grim duty alright I jog I
meditate you know I I go to therapy I
my diet I'm trying to lose weight and
now I got a damn do the damn meditation
stuff you know and it's not about that
it's not about like perfecting yourself
okay I've got to fix my body and I've
got a heal everything and then I've got
to fix my personality and perfect it
it's not about perfecting yourself
it's about perfecting your love can you
live in this world with love for this
human incarnation with all its marbles
and its imperfections there's something
bigger than that
Zen master ryokan the most beloved poet
of Japan he wrote of himself last year a
foolish monk this year no change and and
there's so much tenderness that's like
Quan Yin speaking or here's another
phrase from Quan Yin my old faults like
snow falling on warm ground that there's
a forgiveness and a tenderness in in
that archetype of Quan Yin that says yes
we're human and yes we all get afraid we
make mistakes and we can water the seed
the Magnificent seeds of presence and
care and love all of those are also part
of who we really are and then behind
that we are consciousness having this
great game and that's where your
psychedelics come in my friend tasting
because you were you were you were
beginning that you know I was tiptoeing
around let's jump in you mentioned one
of the argument there are chips of of
American psychedelia ROM das in a sense
at least starting back in his Harvard
days in his previous incarnation is
Richard Alpert so
could you speak to it could be specific
to Ram Dass it could be in the context
of your own life but what what role does
or do psychedelics serve if any and and
that they don't need to be limited to
psychedelics could we we could put it
under the umbrella of secret medicine or
yeah or something else a medicines you
know I've written about this I've
written a number of articles have a
chapter in a book called bringing home
the Dharma where I where I write more
extensively about this there is a long
tradition as we know in many many
spiritual cultures whether the ayahuasca
cultures of the Amazon the African
cultures ibogaine and so forth in the
Indian cultures of Soma that's woven
into the Vedas you know or the Huichol
Indian culture using peyote you know or
the magic mushroom cultures of Central
America and so forth there's this long
beautiful human tradition of using
sacred medicines to help us remember who
we are and because they're so powerful
they're also scary to people because
they take apart our our conventional
reality which is why when Tim Leary and
Richard Alpert back in the old Harvard
days were you know turn on tune in and
drop out were espousing that at the same
time there was the sort of freewheeling
hippie movement of love and peace as
opposed to the war in Vietnam that was a
long time ago half a century ago but it
was also threatening to the culture at
large that was more focused on getting
through school having a job on making a
bunch of money on fulfilling your social
roles and these sacred medicines they
have different dimensions but in the
deepest way they let you
shift your identity from being that
separate sense of self that separate
atom in the acog of you know the culture
and come back to remember love to
remember who you are to have a sense of
mystery and vastness and of course in
the meantime depending which ones you
take they're also quite cleansing and so
you'll find in taking them that you
relive your traumas and if you relive
them in a conscious way you can release
yourself from them I've worked for 40
years or more together with stanislav
grof another of the great elders in the
psychedelic movement and now of course
with the with Michael Pollan's wonderful
book on how to change your mind and the
resurgence of research at Johns Hopkins
and UCLA and weiu and so forth it's
again possible to see the benefits of
these medicines and people are using
them in all kinds of ways now they can
be misused like anything we're Americans
we know how to misuse anything and for
certain people people who have already
you know psychiatric concerns or
histories and so forth they can actually
be dangerous so I don't mean to say that
they're all everything's all hunky-dory
and they can easily be misused as party
drugs and things like that or people
then in wrong circumstances having what
they call a bad trip because they don't
actually understand it but in general
when they're approached as a sacrament
or as a sacred medicine or something in
the simplest way to invite us to learn
from a deep dimension or being they can
be quite magic and you can take
psilocybin mushrooms you know or join a
circle that is drinking the ayahuasca
tea you know and when it's held in the
right set and setting where it's quiet
and your
ended by someone else and you're able to
let go and open in a safe way you'll
find that there's a purification that
takes place a release of things held in
the body and in the emotions of past
difficulties and traumas images and
visions will come and then beyond that
if you allow it
there opens a sense of joy and mystery
and a connection to the consciousness
that you really are and when all these
things are possible in what I've written
almost all the very well-known and
respected teachers of my generation from
the eastern side of our you know
meditation in the West the teachers like
Sharon Salzberg and Joseph Goldstein and
Pema children and you name them they all
started with psychedelics we all did and
it gave us a glimpse into something that
we then wanted to learn further the
beautiful thing is that there's a great
compliment between this and the inner
trainings in meditation when you
meditate you learn how to navigate these
vast spaces and all the intensity of
emotion and healing that come up with a
more gracious and understanding
perspective and in my many many years of
working with Rahm das but especially
with Stan Grof where we lead wreathes
retreats for hundreds and thousands with
holotropic breathwork many people who
were also using these psychedelics at
the same time or near that we learned
and showed people both how to open
through this process and at the same
time how to use the meditative skills of
witnessing of being a loving awareness
of tolerance of opening the window of
tolerance of trust and compassion
holding whatever arises in compassion so
that all the lessons and the openings
would actually land
integrate more integrated and wise way
in their life so I'm excited that these
are now available in our culture and
that people are in a conversation about
how to use them in a healthy and
skillful way and celebrate that as part
of the part of our human heritage of
what we can use to remember that who we
are in the end is love that who we are
as life itself living through us and our
connection that we are as my teacher
said wisdom says I'm nothing and love
says I'm everything that we are
consciousness connected with all things
I remember this image from Alice Walker
who wrote of one character she said one
day I was sitting there like a
motherless child which I was and it come
to me that feeling of being a part of
everything and I knew if I cut a tree my
arm would bleed and I laugh and I cry
and I run all around the house in fact
when it happens you just can't miss it
there is a reality of our
interconnection that is available to us
and we all know it you know we know it
from walking in the high mountains and
having our eyes and senses cleanse and
open we know it from lovemaking and
dissolving into one another into the
field of love we know it from being
there at the birth of a child witnessing
that mystery or holding the hand of
someone at the time of death and seeing
that miraculous moment when spirit
leaves the body and it's that after that
it's just a corpse and realizing that
we're not this body who we are a spirit
itself we know in all these different
ways and the sacred medicines are a way
of bringing us back to that Jack I'd
like to ask you about perhaps about
mistakes or misuses of these plants and
medicines and compounds and so on in the
sense that
just as there are people who use these
tools in the right settings with the
proper preparation proper supervision
guidance and and I should say just as a
caveat neither of us are recommending
anyone do anything with severe legal
side effects in other words many of
these compounds are Schedule one in the
United States and otherwise highly
policed and scheduled and controlled so
follow your local legal restrictions and
requirements but just as there are
people who use these things in
responsible ways there are also people
who are somewhat like a hammer looking
for nails in this sense that they try to
use these tools to fix everything and
anything or they use them I wouldn't say
to escape exactly because these are on
some level anti escapist tools I mean
what you're what you're trying to get
away from is almost certainly going to
come up and stare you right in the face
for an extended period of time which can
be uncomfortable how can these be
overused or abused in abuses of strong
word so let's just say overused well you
know they can become party drugs and I'm
not against parties or people having
that kind of dance and loving connection
so forth but they can be used in ways
that are superficial if you say that you
know in which or they can be used in
this setting where you can get lost or
frightened in the setting because it's
not really very well contained or on
occasion of the beautiful thing about
most of the psychedelics is that they're
not particularly addictive which is a
great relief however human beings you
know we can still try alright on taking
a lot a lot a lot and see what happens
and that's not particularly helpful or
healthy that's another way of misusing
it or trying to get somebody else to do
that they should be approached with
respect and a pro
with that respect means also you know
not too frequent and that you have to
ask your own heart well what does that
mean how much can I learn from it how do
i integrate it can I take some time
afterward you know it's it's not like
piling on and the truth is that none of
these things is is it kind of magic cure
as you said that you're just going to
fix everything with it because it
doesn't work that way
each of these are opportunities for
healing for understanding or opening to
continue and all that bless it that's
great
you want to take the journey and not
kind of leap ahead and you started
somehow early on talk about the
difference between development and
fruition the fruition lens of becoming
the consciousness the one who knows you
can have that perspective and because we
are paradoxical you also still need to
do the inner work or even if you have
had a beautiful vast meditation or a
psychedelic trip or something that's
opened you like that
still there'll be places that you're
caught and they'll be trauma that you
carry and that becomes the place to
develop compassion open the window of
tolerance allow that healing to take
place and understand that we're
multi-dimensional beings and so yeah I
mean these are part of the work it's so
mysterious we are mysterious spiritual
beings and these help open the gate but
so does poetry you know so does looking
deeply in the eyes of another person so
does going out onto the ocean and seeing
its vastness or walking in the high
mountains these are all our birthright
so it is even the mystery of sleep you
know I mean we want to sleep and you
talked about you know wanting to sleep
and I find that what I can't sleep and
mostly I'm able to sleep pretty easily
I get up and I meditate say okay it's
given to me time to meditate and then I
noticed my - maybe thinking about
something or obsessing or worried or
something
oh yeah thank you for trying to take
care of me it's okay and I go back to my
compassion practice or to the vastness
and after a while I get bored and I go
back to sleep but there's some way in
which sleep is mysterious
you know Tim here we are and then every
day we long to go unconscious let's
forget about the dream part we do it's
like oh can I only have a period where I
disappear you know people are worried
about disappearing in meditation
hallelujah can I have a period where I
disappear and I'm not so self-involved
with my life and all the things I have
to do in love and hate and so forth
please give me a little peace you know
it's it's such a weird thing that the
beings being sleep nobody looks at these
things it's just like eating you have
this hole at the top of your body into
which you stuff dead plants and animals
regularly grind them up with these bones
that hang down and glug them down
through the tube you know and you you
ambulate it by following one direction
and catching yourself and you follow the
other side and you catch yourself I mean
how did you get into this weird thing
you know so we've lost that sense of
mystery sleep is one of the great
mysteries and we love it so when you
have that sense that instead of being
success or failure it's like oh you get
to you get to see this mystery and
realize that it's connected with
everything yeah you mentioned stan
stanislav grof earlier yes Groff was
very fortunate to have on the podcast
before his stroke not too long ago which
which I think he's largely recovered
from in terms of writing but had some
aphasia afterwards much like Ram Dass
did although not that severe he I
believe
has certainly spoken extensively on
these topics and one of his observations
I'm going to paraphrase here that is I
believe in his most recent book or
actually a combination of two books it
related to suicide and attempts at
suicide perhaps being attempts to free
oneself from the ego but thinking that
the only path available for that is
extinguishing your physical form and
that part of the reason you see efficacy
with certain psychedelics as has been
shown at least in certain clinical
studies done with psilocybin the ability
to reduce end-of-life anxiety and
terminal cancer patients or even address
say treatment resistant depression is in
part because just as we long for sleep
to go unconscious in a sense or go
subconscious it's that the temporary
alleviation of the burden of
self-centeredness and this sort of
recursive self referential prison that
we can create for ourselves this is I do
think that's an astute observation about
sleep I just want to underscore a few
things you said also one is that I do
think for anyone who is considering any
type of psychedelic experience it is it
is incredibly valuable to put on a
little bit of mileage with a regular
meditation practice and to practice even
in a the somewhat volume turned down
sense sitting with emotions that may be
difficult or thoughts that may be
unpleasant for say a consecutive 30-day
period meaning daily for 30 days or 60
days minimum before considering a larger
psychedelic experience that would be
certainly something I would strongly
suggest and it's akin to on some level
drinking from the water fountain before
you drink from the garden hose before
you drink from the fire hose I think
that they can be complimentary in a lot
of respects but I do think it's it's a
pretty good advice it's really good
advice and and and also if you're gonna
do it
the other dangers you want to have make
sure that the source of that sacred
medicine is clean and good and not just
Street stuff and you want to have a
sitter
for people who do it's it's like going
out and to you know an astronaut you
want to containment so you want someone
who's not taking that to sit with you
tend you give you whatever you need to
keep you warm give you something to
drink a foster or a sense that you're
protected so that what needs to happen
in wordly is held in this sacred set and
setting and that makes all the
difference
now what Stan said what Stan Grof said
about about suicide - let me paraphrase
it in a pretty similar way that when
people feel that they want to commit
suicide they are right that something
needs to die they're mistaken in
thinking that it's their body that has
to die there but they're facing
something that really does have to die
and changing it may be the way their
whole way they're living their life it
may be you know the history that they
have that they have to die to that you
know you could call it an ego death some
sense of identity that they've had that
they don't want to let go of but they
have to some difficulty so there's some
way in which just as you point to the
deep inner work of a psychedelic session
where there comes a go death or a death
of the way we hold ourselves and all
that we go through is coming to that
that transforms us and we realize it's
it's the problem is in our body that
problem is actually in our own heart and
mind
now if anybody is interested in you know
a wise perspective on the nature of
consciousness the my favorite book of
Stan Groff's is a book called the cosmic
game
now in which you can get like everything
on online and it's a description he he
described five thousand people five
thousand sessions saving with people
whether they did LSD or holotropic
breathing or other sacred medicines and
it's a summary of the deepest insights
and understandings that have come and
it's a very beautiful framework for
understanding the nature of
consciousness itself now the other thing
that you're sort of pointing to Tim has
to do with Amon Amarth ongoing themes
has to do with trauma and and how do we
deal with that as it comes up whether
it's in a psychedelic session or you
know in our meditation or just in our
lives so there's that and then I'm also
so we could go there I'm also
remembering sitting with Ram Dass when
oh gosh my mind is blanking what's the
name of the researcher Johns Hopkins
who's been doing all the psychedelic
research rollin rollin Griffiths is
roland griffiths alright so was the
director of the center rollin rollin had
come to visit ramadasa it was probably
last year or year two ago and they had
never met in person but rollin in a way
has been picking up that psychedelic
work that was left off almost fifty
years ago by stanislav grof who was the
last LSD researcher legitimately doing
that work it and he was again at Johns
Hopkins and so they shared stories and
it was was actually quite a beautiful
afternoon because Ram Dass told him
about the Good Friday experiment with
clergy in you know back in the 1960s in
Boston and how various clergy members
had had experiences of God and
experiences of deep religious awakening
in this and then Rolen was a you know
describing what he'd learned and it was
like a passing of the torch so much love
that was there in the room which is of
course what ROM dust was like in these
last year's
and then Roland said he said the thing
that makes the biggest difference for
those who come through our studies
whether they're they're healed whether
they're able to approach their death in
a more peaceful way or whether they had
great trauma and that starts to heal or
they had depression or addiction he said
the various groups that we were working
with he said one of the scales that
we're using to measure the experience is
a scale for mystical experiences and he
said I can see in our data quite simply
that if someone has any went on and many
of our people do a truly a full-blown or
a truly deep mystical experience
everything shifts in their life and so
this is the invitation from meditation
itself or from these psychedelics in the
right setting because remember the way
that it's done at Hopkins is with a
blindfold on and earphone you know so
that your your trip is entirely interior
and your attended by someone and it
allows you to go into the depths of your
own being so this is really different
than you know party tripping or
something like that very different very
very different people can learn more
about that program at Hopkins
psychedelic org also where you can see
not just rolling but many other team
members who are absolutely incredible
Mary Cusimano of course you have Matt
Johnson many other scientists and
researchers so it's worth looking at the
the studies and the science that is
being done there which is has really
sort of set the bar for how these
compounds are researched in the last few
decades and hopefully moving forward
question for you about trauma let's
let's jump into it how sure
how would you suggest people think about
trauma you and I and I may speak
publicly about this more another time
but you and I have had a lot of
conversations over the last say four or
five years and I feel like my response
to the current circumstances in the
world kovat 19 and it's and so on is
really an exaggerated display of the
hyper vigilance that as a result of
childhood trauma and I like I couldn't
prove that in a mathematical proof but
it seems somewhat self-evident to me and
I would anticipate in some capacity how
should people think about trauma how do
you think about trauma so I want to take
a pause here you know we're talking
about a lot of things that are actually
very deep in our human experience we
started with the virus itself and the
fact that we human beings have
periodically lived through epidemics and
that many people have died and it's not
just you know that one becomes calm but
that it's really something huge to be
able to try to hold it's like people
living through warfare I wish I could
say well that's human history as in the
past history but it's current and we
have these streams refugees from war
zones in Syria or Sudan or other places
or the undeclared wars in the streets
and you know Central America between
gangs and parts of our country wherever
it is so first I just want to feel the
weight of this in our human life and
take a breath and say so this is a this
is a you know a deep question for us as
human beings how do we hold this what's
true is that in our lives those who are
listening in yourself and and for myself
many of us have some significant trauma
in our path
and if we're not aware of it
or don't have a way to manage it then we
can become over vigilant as you
described we can unconsciously manage it
through addictions by drinking or
drugging or using in all kinds of other
ways or eating or sex or whatever it is
in ways that are unhealthy addictive
patterns we can live our life in a last
year
so to understand traumas is really
important and for anyone who's working
in the realm of the psyche of the heart
and mind whether is a psychologist or
spiritual and I can't even divide them
it's just who we are as humans
understanding trauma is important trauma
in the simplest way it speaks of an
experience of suffering of some kind
physical or emotional pain of some kind
or other that's happened in which our
body goes into its fight flight or
freeze a kind of survival and then that
gets locked into our bodies and hearts
and minds sometimes we can have
difficulties and process them somewhat
be there for it feel the feelings feel
at all and and and live through it and
release it and then it doesn't become
trauma it becomes part of our history
something that we've learned and that's
more how animals do it apparently one of
the great trauma experts Peter Levine
has these videos which show for example
a I think it's of a great big Jackrabbit
being chased by a coyote and it's
running as fast as it can and the
Coyotes running as fast as it can you
could see it absolutely terrified and
then all of a sudden I don't know some
other larger coyote or something comes
along and distracts the coyote that's
chasing it and the the the hare the
rabbit giant hare ducks down a hole
and escapes and you see the Coyotes
sniffing around for a while like where
did it go and then it saunters off and
then you see the hair come back out of
the hole or wherever it ducked into and
it starts weird it starts to dance it
starts to jump around as if it's
releasing all the tension and all the
struggle that was there in that
life-or-death chase and it does that for
a while and then it settles down and
then it kind of hops along and goes on
its way well for us as human beings when
we're children and you know whether
we're abandoned or abused or terrible
things happen or as adults as well where
there's an accident or even surgery
where they put our put us to sleep but
our body you knows it it remembers it we
don't release that and it gets stuck and
to the extent that we have major trauma
that's unrecognized or unreleased as I
said it it takes over in some
unconscious way our life so let me tell
a couple of examples that help give a
perspective the release of trauma
happens again because we're beings of
multi layers or multi dimensions it
happens in different dimensions there's
a physical dimension of it so when you
start to remember or recognize that you
may already have some memories that
there is trauma one part of it and it
can be in therapy or sitting with a very
good trauma person the people who are
trained by Peter Levine's somatic
experience or EMDR or or Bessel Vander
coax practices and so forth that you
start to remember as best you can start
to tell the story and then feel what it
does in your body and your body's going
to want to start to move and tighten and
release and if you're able to be with
someone or with yourself over
a period of time and tolerate that
gradually what's been held in the body
gets released the second dimension of it
is the emotions and I know this very
well from people who face trauma arising
in their meditation on retreats that I
teach and I'll have them close their
eyes and the images from the past will
arise and then with them come all the
emotions of terror fear of weeping of
rage or grief and all those things that
get stuck in that child or in that
person even in your body you know when
there was the accident or there was the
trauma you know of being abandoned in
some terrible way all those emotions
arise and to be able to tolerate them
and make often with the help of another
person make a field of presence and
compassion that can allow those to be
released becomes important and then
there's the mental dimension of telling
the story so having worked with vets who
returned back from Afghanistan and Iraq
and Kuwait Middle East especially but
other places as well and led retreats
with my colleagues Michael Meade Louisa
Rodriguez this wonderful Latin poet and
activist Mallard omasum a West African
medicine man when debts returned and
it's all the more so from the women who
were vets they can't tell their stories
to their families to the people around
them because they're too horrific and
you know what he wants to go home you
know and I have to tell the stories of
the things that that they've been
through it's too difficult but when we
get combat vets together and make a safe
place and create a ritual where we light
a candle and make a ritual space and say
this is where we can hold the suffering
in the the horrors that you have lived
through
the humanity of it and who we really are
and they begin to tell their stories
there are two kinds of stories the first
part is I can't tell you what I saw and
then they'll go ahead and tell stories
and the other combat that's all know
this and then the more difficult story
is I can't tell you what I had to do
what I was forced to do and then the
real grief comes even deeper because
it's a betrayal of our soul in some way
you know to to be forced to kill other
people and the fact that they're able to
tell their stories and be witnessed you
know that a person can tell the story of
what really happened to them as a child
and be witness with a loving gaze and
with an understanding of how much
suffering that was and how it's held in
the body and the emotions and to realize
that it's not who you are that who you
are so much bigger than that has an
enormous ly transformative effect and at
the end of these retreats for veterans
they would then stand up we'd invite
family and community members to come and
they would tell a little of their story
or read a part of a poem they wrote or
something and finally get some of it out
to everyone else to hear and then they
would be ritually and symbolically and
literally welcomed back into the
community we hear you we now understand
what you've gone through and you're you
are one of us we welcome you home and it
makes me wonder you know and worry about
all those thousands and hundreds of
thousands who were just let off the
busses back home and no one really
helped them with the stories and the
wounds that they carry and of course I'm
talking about military but I could be
talking about you Tim or me where my
father was incredibly violent and would
throw my mother down the stairs or beat
her black and blue so she had to wear
long sleeves in the summer so people
wouldn't see how much she was battered
by him you know and how it was to stand
there and witness that or have his rage
turn on us and it took me a long time to
deal with the pain and the anger I
didn't even want to feel how much anger
I had because I didn't want to be like
him but then as I meditated I realized
it wasn't just out there that it was in
me as well and so these are all
dimensions of healing of the body of the
emotions and the heart and of the story
and one of the great gifts of being with
Ram Dass in these last years is that he
became he became transparent he became a
lighthouse of love you would just sit
and he would gaze at you with what in
India was called the glance of mercy the
eyes of that guru that being whoever she
or he is that looks at you with so much
love and you go la blaw I felt this and
I've done that and I feel so and your
whole story and your pain and your
suffering and they just look at you with
so much love and you remember that
that's not who you are all that trauma
and so we can do that for one another in
these deep healing ways so that's the
beginning of you know your question
about trauma thank you jack well I I
think that's number one I would like to
have you back for a third installment
sooner rather than later I'm ashamed
that it took so long to have you back on
so that's the first thing I would like
to say you know no pressure to to accept
the invitation now but I would love to
have another installment of this
conversation for public consumption and
I think this is I think this is a
sensible place to talk about what you're
up to now and perhaps tie up this
conversation because it's it
provided a lot for people to chew on and
think about and hopefully apply and and
use I have all sorts of follow-up
questions that I will ask another time
but the one that I can't push off is
asking you what you are focused on these
days so what is I get that I'll get to
that in just a minute and yes I hope
next time we can talk about climate
change we can talk about servant
leadership because I did some teaching
and meditation in the UK Parliament with
people from both sides of the aisle and
what that was like are working in
Palestine and Israel and things like
that I'd love to talk about all those
many many more things like this I want
to say one more thing from around us and
then it connects to directly to answer
your question of what I'm working on and
that is that we held a couple of there
been whole series of memorials for Ram
Dass as a spiritual friend and teacher
and colleague who died in December and I
was fortunate enough to teach with him
and be with him in December not long
before he died and he was so loving that
when the retreat ended that the last day
they give a little set of beads with a
thread from his guru's blanket tied into
it and all 350 people would pass by Rama
Das who was seated there and who didn't
have a lot of words because his aphasia
had gotten worse sequence because much
toward the end of his life and he just
gazed at them with so much love that
people would stand there and start to
weep and at the memorial Krishna Das who
is a colleague and a friend and a quite
famous musician who does chanting that
you hear often in yoga studios around
the country and so forth
krishna das told a story he said I first
met ROM das when I was 18 years old
and Ram Dass had just come back from
India and was wearing his white robes
his beard and he was teaching and
krishna das said it was the most
compelling spiritual voice i'd ever
heard and i just wanted to follow him
and i went back to india spent time with
his guru maharaji and spent time around
rom das in the community it really
became part of it and have for years now
and he said I can tell you this after
this 40 years have passed
he said Ram Dass became the person we
thought he was when we first met him it
was a really a beautiful and rich
comment that talks about all of us
because in some way we already know and
in another way were works in progress
right of becoming but it's also it's
gorgeous because it means that we can
become that love and we come can become
that loving awareness that's who we
really are more and more in our life so
the one thing that I will say then to
answer your question I'm involved in
other projects in Silicon Valley and
with trying to humanize the future of
technology and AI and that would be
another topic and writing new things and
so forth but I've got a training program
for people who are interested in
teaching meditation if you've been a
mindfulness practitioner for you know a
few years or a meditator for some years
and you're interested in passing it on
to others it turns out to be one of the
most delicious and transformed of things
you can do with your life and it doesn't
mean it becomes your whole life but one
thing that you can do becoming a
meditation teacher and so Ouattara brock
we have this online training program to
which we poured our very best teachings
in our hearts it's a two-year online
program that's really quite wonderful
that you can find out about by going on
to my website jack Kornfield com and it
involves a few in-person short retreats
if you can do them mostly online you
become mentored you become part of a
small group and you have a wonderful
teacher as a mentor and you have a whole
group of others that you're training
with and we now have people in 50
countries around the world doing it and
it transforms their lives and then they
take it into their schools and
businesses and communities and health
centers and so forth so it's a beautiful
thing to do and I'm excited because
we've just put everything that we know
that's good in it and people learned so
much and they become part of an amazing
community so that's my current favorite
activity talking with you
TM and along with you know I'm getting
the holding my beloved Trudy my my wife
and Dharma partner and you know Lawton
and walking out in the spring blossoms
here in the Bay Area well you have you
have many projects I want to highlight
this one for a second because I have
spent time with you in person I have
spent time with you on retreat I think
you are an incredible teacher you're
also an incredible clinician and you
have toolkits beyond that of perhaps the
prototypical mindfulness or meditation
teacher so I want to also just give a
nod to the expansive toolkit that both
you and tarah have so I want to mention
also tarah because at our Brock is the
author of a book that was recommended to
me that I have also recommend to many
many people called radical acceptance
which has had a large impact in my lifes
the fact that the two of you are
offering this teacher training in effect
for those interested in meditation I
think is just a tremendous opportunity
and I don't say that lightly I say that
as someone who has spent time in live
discussion with both of you and spent
time in person with you and seeing what
both of you can do as practitioners and
as teachers so I highly highly recommend
that if you've ever thought about not
just learning more about how to meditate
but as a practitioner how to teach this
how to help others that you go to jack
Kornfield comm and take a look and I
would say not to make this a hard sell
because it's not a hard sell I don't
have any skin in this game I don't get
anything from it other than hopefully
introducing you to - spectacular
teachers that it's very likely that
you're going to be spending more time
online from this point forward for the
next few months and it makes sense at
least to me to look for opportunities
and there are many different options to
feel connected and some cohesion with a
group that is not in a physical location
so this also presents I think a an
excellent option for embracing and
cultivating that if it makes sense so I
will get off my soapbox but since you're
very understated I wanted to at least
just draw a couple of my months I
appreciate it and I also appreciate our
friendship I appreciate that we've
gotten to know each other and some
really important and deep ways and I so
value the work that you do and the heart
and care that you put out to all the
people that listen so thank you for the
opportunity and thank you to all those
of you who listened thanks so much jack
and where else can people say hello if
they want to say hello I have at jack
Kornfield on Twitter there anything else
you'd like to mention jack Kornfield
comm of course that's probably
sufficient or they think we can wave at
the market but you know as we as we walk
by but for the moment we'll issue the
hugs and just make a little cleanliness
bow to one another as they go by sounds
good Jack well it's always such a
pleasure to spend time with you and to
learn from you I really appreciate it
this is done I think I've probably from
hitting record to now probably lowered
my blood pressure 20 points
so I appreciate that also and I can't
wait for our next conversation so thanks
again for blocking out the time to have
a chat
my pleasure Tim take good care you too
and to everybody listening thanks for
tuning in and you can find show notes
links to everything we have discussed as
always at tim vlog forward slash podcast
so until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric
as I do it could include favorite
articles that I've read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out just go to
4-hour workweek dot-com that's 4-hour
workweek com all spelled out and just
drop in with your email and you'll get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for you to find and work with
amazing graphic designers online
longtime listeners of this podcast know
how much attention I paid to detail how
obsessively I approached nearly all
elements of my work because the small
things often end up being the big things
so whether it's your logo your business
cards website design even your email
templates all of these visual elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about so I think
it's worth sweating the details I've
been using 99designs for years now to
ensure that many of my creative projects
whether big or small are as cohesive
professional and beauty
as possible I've worked on draft
mock-ups of book covers I've worked on
all sorts of bugs most recently I've
been working with a designer at
99designs to update the illustrations
and layouts for all of my downloadable
ebooks I've developed a really great
working relationship with designer who
goes by the username spoon Lancer and I
intend to continue working with him to
bring ideas to life one project at a
time I've also used nine nine designs
for all sorts of high-end illustration
for different books like the Tao Seneca
you can see a bunch of examples on my
Instagram that I've put up and they've
turned out better than I possibly could
have hope so from logos to websites to
packaging to books 99 designs is the go
to creative resource to build your brand
on any budget so check them out right
now my listeners that's you guys can get
$20 off plus a free $99 upgrade on their
first design contest the contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer for long-term work you
can also book a free design consultation
with a brand expert at 99 designs to
receive personalized branding advice
over the phone they're hands-on team has
helped thousands of business owners at
this point it's a great way to get the
most out of your experience with 99
designs so take a look head to 99
designs dot-com / Tim for your discount
and to sign up for a design consultation
today that's 99 designs comm / Tim this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
longtime listeners in this podcast know
that I've been talking about fresh books
for years it's the all-in-one invoice me
payments and accounting solution it came
about because I was doing a revision of
the 4-hour workweek for 2009 looking at
new software solutions that could help
people help my readers and fresh books
came up over and over and over again
many entrepreneurs as well as
contractors and freelancers I work with
all the time use fresh books more and
more every day why is that
well most people especially
entrepreneurs business builders hate
wasting time doing things in efficiently
painful invoicing with different cobbles
together solutions into the word or self
you fall into that category you want to
avoid that pain what can you do give
fresh books a try
fresh books is accounting software that
makes invoicing and other bookkeeping
tasks so easy you can save up to 200
hours per year that's a lot of hours
here's how it makes running your
business easier you can automate bank
reconciliation in just a few clicks you
can give your accountant access to the
information they need to do your taxes
this is a huge one I've realized how
important this is and how much it makes
life easier when you get this done with
many things you can't accept credit card
ACH payments right on invoices to get
paid two times faster and of course you
can create customized and sound branded
and professional-looking invoices in
about 30 seconds with plans starting at
just 15 dollars per month fresh books is
designed to grow with your business and
right now first books is offering my
listeners that's you guys a free 30-day
trial with no credit card required
simply go to fresh books.com slash tim
and enter tim ferriss in the how did you
hear about us section that's Ferriss
with two R's classes of course check it
out
go to fresh books calm / 10 and start
your free 30-day trial today first books
calm
you
you